ضاره نافعه هذا هو حال الجيش الاوكراني
بعد اعلان قوات فاجنر السيطره على مدينه
باخموت نيويورك تايمز قالت في تقرير لها
ان محاوله روسيا الاحتفاظ بالمدينه ربما
ستدفعها لارسال تعزيزات في محاوله لتثبيت
سيطرتها على
وبالفعل اشار تقرير استخبارات بريطانيا
يوم السبت الى ان موسكو اعادت انتشار عده
كتائب لتعزيز قواتها في بخموت اوكرانيا
بحسب
ستلجا للاستيلاء على المرتفعات حول باخوه
هذه المرتفعات التي نراها وهو ما اكدته
فعليا النائبه وزير الدفاع هنا ماليور
عندما قالت ان القوات الاوكرانيه استعادت
مرتفعات شمال وجنوب المدينه ما سيعقد وجود
الروس في باخموت اوكرانيا ستواصل ايضا
تطبيق المدينه من عده جهات في محاوله
لاستنزاف القوات الروسيه داخل باخموت
وتحويلها
احرقه لهذه القوات ولم تكتفي اوكرانيا
بذلك بل واصلت جلب تعزيزات لدعم المواقع
الخلفيه وايضا تامين طرق الامداد غرب اخد
في الجانب الروسي تواجه القوات تحديات عده
فقائد مجموعه فاجنر اعلنت تسليم المدينه
للجيش الروسي يوم الخميس لكن الانسحاب على
طول خط المواجهه لن يتم دون عواقب حتى على
الروس في المدينه وفق نيويورك تايمز كما
ان استنفاذ عده وحدات روسيه لقواها سيضع
روسيا في موقف دفاعي عبر كل خط المواجهه
تقريبا والذي يمتد لمئات الكيلومترات
بعدما ركزت موسكو على السيطره على بخموت
بطبيعه الحال وهنا يبدو ان استنزاف القوات
الروسيه على اختلاف مسمياتها سيضعف قدرتها
على صد الهجوم المضاد الذي تخطط له
اوكرانيا في شرق البلاد وفق خبراء عسكريين
لم تابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات